hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
it's me it's that guy I know who I I
think I know what my own name is but
anyway it's Mike frieder here with an
on-call compliance Solutions and I'm
back with another compliance tip of the
week and zero editing uh this week we're
talking about cmmc control mp.l
2-3.8.4 Mark media would necessary Cy
markings and distribution limitations oh
the dreaded cui marking let's learn
about it
[Music]
all right so hey if you're a defense
contractor who's feeling overwhelmed
tired and alone trying to understand all
this cmmc dfars and nist sp171
compliance stuff or just understanding
how to pronounce it on top of an already
colossal workload well I've got great
news for you you found your home here at
on-call compliance Solutions where we
can help you transform into your
company's on co-compliance Hero Let's
jump into it
oh yeah the dreaded cui marking yes
you must Mark cui there is no way around
it it's written right here and I'm not
going to make yet another joke about
cuisupply.com
at least not until they call us and
sponsor one of our videos
cysupply.com where you at
can make you so much money uh I don't
know who did that but man kudos to that
guy uh I do love their stickers though
and uh you know what shout out to
whoever made that site I think you're
very clever and if you ever get tired of
running it call me let's work out a deal
I'll buy it from you and uh I'll I'll
just really have a lot of fun making
even cooler stickers meanwhile there
exists a cui marking handbook to give us
guidance and of course every company is
different so we always advocate for
being able to work one-on-one to devise
the most efficient compliant and
effective marketing strategy that will
have the least amount of budgetary and
operational impact on you man I feel
like that was a lot of super big words
uh and whoever writes these scripts must
for sure be above a third grade reading
level which I am not uh and we're going
to have to dumb it down so I can
understand what I'm reading here anyway
let's see let's see what it uh what it
is that will make the assessors happy on
this one all right two things determine
if media contains cui is marked with
applicable cui markings uh the
organization follows the guidance within
the Cy marking handbook hint there's
actually a handbook that tells you how
to do it it's a riveting read you guys
it's like right there like if you jam
Harry Potter the first three Editions
into 21 pages
it would be much more exciting than this
not gonna not gonna lie to you
it's pretty dry it's like we're you know
uh we're in here in studio we were
talking about like making dry jokes and
I was like yeah how we make like
sandpaper dry jokes like
they'll rub you the wrong way anyway uh
what else are they suggesting you on uh
determining if media containing cuis
marked with get it sandpaper runs the
wrong way
ah
dad jokes all right the turn of media
contains Cy is marked with distribution
limitations uh and again obviously if
you have any they need distribution
limitations they would have to be marked
and that's one of those things you
honestly you're just going to give a
demonstration so you're going to whip
out some paper it's got cui markings on
it hopefully you got some of that right
uh not all organizations do by the way
uh and you're gonna demonstrate the
assessor uh cui marketing examples
uh Hey an on-call turns out guess what
we work with defense contractors just
like
you uh who have had the steepfar's nest
itar and cmoc compliance stuff dropped
in their laps like a seagull on a sunny
day we teach you how to level up and be
a proper on-call compliance hero for
your company eliminating gaps great
areas and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
is your secret weapon to land more
Defense work with higher profit margins
now that's what becoming an on-call
compliance hero can do for you if you're
looking for more help getting compliant
our on-call compliance experts are
always on call for you which is why we
call them on-call compliance experts
somebody hit the pace button one too
many times but that's okay because if
you're watching this video you'll get a
whole lot more of that if you go to cmmc
compliance secrets.com baby cmfc
compliance Secrets why because it
shouldn't be a secret how to comply with
cmmc it should be easy
well we try to do the best we can or
check out the Bible below for the links
uh that will help make your life a whole
lot better love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button before the next piece of content
comes out because then you would get the
alert that the piece of content came out
that's the point of subscribing and and
if you just try it you'll find out that
it works
um I like to personally I like to try
before I buy that's like what the
Subscribe button is all about I try it
now you try a lot of new things actually
I'm a very open-minded person
um and subscribing to my channel is one
of them until the next compliance tip my
friends
stay safe and secure
let us know what you want to know more
about in the comments below and I'll see
you on the next one
[Music]